sure I guess you could call me a super  fanny I'd be on the district well clan  Mockingjay debuts November 21 guess what  I'm in line before anyone this is my  hunger games three weeks  it stormed before but now I'm dryer cuz  I'm sunburned yeah I'm the girl on fire  i juiced up all my sick days this year  so I'm fired but this is more important  than some career this is my hunger a  love bite through the  hose in  before the premiere oh my goodness for  that chachacha to know I'm hallucinating  this is fun I should shower and tell my  family where I am but who needs hygiene  when you're a true fan  a final  hey you on my turf yep be afraid I chip  shot a guy with an era lo mein I'm  surviving on shrubs and trash popcorn  you think that I'm in sync well I'm not  insane you're the insane one shop this  is real can disappear to date me  this is my hunger games I'm fight role  in the year one minute before the  premiere  you  Oh